foreign
a woman accused of dealing
methamphetamine is on the run here in
southern Nevada and tonight eight news
now investigator Vanessa Murphy brings
you the latest Manhunt Monday and where
the U.S Marshals say she likes to
frequent
Sabrina Bradley is accused of dealing a
large quantity of meth in Iowa through
Facebook Messenger since she was
indicted by a Federal grand jury in 2021
she's had a couple of chances at freedom
but according to the U.S Marshals she
blew it she was initially released on
Bond and was complying she instantly
absconded rayvenagus is a supervisory
Deputy U.S Marshal his team is searching
for Bradley and he says they believe she
is in the Las Vegas area is she
considered dangerous well she doesn't
have a violent criminal history she is
considered dangerous due to the fact
that she was Distributing narcotics the
U.S Marshals say she's also known to
abuse drugs another Vice gambling they
say she's known to frequent local spots
like different Dotties locations mainly
on the northeast part of Las Vegas and
she has family ties in Pahrump she's not
doing a whole lot to hide herself yeah
she's doing a pretty good job at hiding
yourself in August of 2022 shortly after
Bradley first appeared in federal court
in Nevada for that warrant in Iowa she
was released with conditions one of them
to show up at Future court dates one
date was even pushed back to accommodate
her still Bradley was a no-show she was
scheduled to go to trial last March
since she's a fugitive that hasn't
happened now the U.S Marshals are asking
anyone who sees her to report it don't
approach her do notify law enforcement
Vanessa Murphy 8 News Now
anyone with information is asked to call
the U.S Marshals service communications
center the number on your screen
1-877-926-8332 or you can also call
Crime Stoppers and remain anonymous
again that number is 702-385-555